رئيس الفرنسي مانيويل ماكوم مصر على
اللاقات الثلاث لا للتراجع عن قانون نظام
التقاعد لا لتعديل وزاري ولا لحل مجلس
النواب ورغم الحراك الاحتجاجيه الذي شارك
فيها اكثر من مليون شخص وفقه وزاره
الداخليه ولكن انضمام الشباب وطلاب الى
الحراك اعطى نفحه جديده للتظاهرات واظهر
عمق الازمه الداخليه التي تواجه ماكرون
بعدما قرر طلاب اغلاق المدارس الثانويه
الخاصه بهم كما تقول هنا صحيفه الجارديون
البريطانيه التي اعتبرت ان الطلاب كانوا
بعيدين في المرحله الاولى من التظاهرات
التي تقودها النقابات العماليه واضرابات
النقل ضد خطه ماكرون لرفع سنه التقاعد الى
64 عاما الا انهم تقدموا الى الساحه مؤخرا
لانتزاع حقوقهم الاجتماعيه من الحكومه
وتحديدا بعد استخدام العنف المفرط من قبل
الشرطه الفرنسيه بوجه المظاهرين وتعنت
الحكومه في قراراتها رغم الصرخه الشعبيه
الكبيره ضد هذه المطالب هنا قدرت الصحيفه
البريطانيه اعداد الطلاب باكثر من 90 الف
طالب اي ثلاثه اضعاف من حضروا الاسبوع
الماضي هذا المشهد سيقيد عمل الشرطه
وسيرضعها طبعا عن استخدام العنف المفرط ضد
تلاميذ تتراوح اعمارهم بين 17 عاما
وثمانيه عشر عاما المشهد الفرنسي مشاهدينا
المطرب بسبب الذعر وفق صحيفه نموض
الفرنسيه قالت بان البلد ينهار بعدما الغى
الملك تشارلز زيارته الى باريس معتبره ان
هذا القرار اضر بهيبه الدوله الفرنسيه
فيما لا يزال ماكرون مصرا على موقفه